dans tout groupe civilisé il y à un
paria
dès son plus jeune âge le paria a du mal
à s'intégrer
il peut parfois se sentir visé et
souvent ils peinent à se faire des amis
mais malgré toutes ces difficultés le
paria persiste à vouloir tisser des
liens
un copeau salutations comme on s'est
montrés nous serions honorés de gagner
votre amitié
savez vous laisse à vos goûts vos amis
personne ne voit ce qui se passe sur
notre île ces cochons sont mystérieux et
bizarre non mouais c'est vraiment ça que
j'aime bien depuis ce joli sans pente
nous n'avons que faire de ton opinion
tête carrée mulder ce gars vient de se
faire clouer le bec
les grosses ovale nous sommes allés
capture link et watson que faisons nous
c'est à moi de vous le dire nous avertir
nous avons fait la sourde oreille
on va récupérer nos deux vous fait quoi
là on est des oiseaux ou qu'elles sont
des dinosaures
sur le papier on n'est pas des gens
ouais tu m'as fait pareil qu'est ce que
tu veux porter quand tu seras pas
reposant très bons amis lâchez vos
doigts il suit mais moi maintenant et en
colère
ma prof de yoga dire des boules de feu
avec ses fesses
j'y serai
moisson rouge dans nos murs rapt et demi
nous par l'intérieur des murs dans le
sacco un peu de sérieux les gars
chaque bolide une horreur